graduated high school crushed it
straight A's boom help my classmates was
kind of kind and helpful and expected
them to be meanwhile they put me down
mocked me never loved me in a room with
30 people I was always alone inner voice
tells me to go after the past seek
revenge keep looking at their profiles
profiles like online program yeah social
media yeah yeah should I go now he's got
a series of questions here yeah should I
go after them and try to fix the past
either by revenge or else should I
should I remove them from social media
and leave the the Facebook group should
I attend the reunion
why have they even been in my life okay
so let's break those down number one
should I go after them and try to fix
the past either by revenge or something
else the answer that
in my opinion is no man who cares
they're highschool kids move on get on
with your life yeah disagree agree agree
okay that that one to me is pretty
straightforward
mhm don't worry about these humans I
actually had a couple conversations with
with my oldest daughters haven't had
this one with my son yet but my older
daughters which is hey look these people
that are around right now that you think
are so important in high school mmm
they're hot you know some of them might
be you might have some lifelong friends
from high school I get that but these
people that are not nice to you you
won't be thinking about them so I don't
I'm not sure how old this individual is
but he's got a couple more years before
he won't be thinking about these people
anymore so just get there earlier
question two should I remove them from
social media and leave this Facebook
group okay this is a little bit tricky
in my opinion first of all if you can if
you can stay if you can keep them on
social media but ignore them completely
just leave them alone just leave it in
just totally ignore them because when
you leave them or whatever you're kind
of aren't you kind of making this scene
yes okay I just want to make sure so you
don't to make a scene well yeah like
when you unfriend them which didn't you
and I have some situations with yeah
yeah it's okay so I know that I won't
wait who on friended you my wife yep
okay
so you did it well no no I didn't even
know how to do it not but I I figured it
no I didn't so I didn't ever have social
media until two years ago but all of a
sudden I saw Echo friends with my wife
that's weird she's like showing me
something and she says and I see Echo
and I said why are you friends with
people that why you friends with people
that I know I'll click unfriend on that
and I didn't even know as a big deal I
just thought you know hey that means and
and then I didn't realize a big deal
it's a big one man
yeah unfriended him messed up I thought
you did it purposely knowing it's a big
deal but not understanding that it's
even a bigger deal then you know how are
you like unfriend him as a joke that was
like it was totally your personality at
that oh you thought I did that to you
yeah like as a joke like unfriend him
you don't say something to me like
immediately or was it did did a month go
by where I didn't make a joke about it
so so it is kind of making a scene if
you if you unfriend this person or you
leave the group then you're just
creating a little firestorm but I will
say this if you can't if you can't keep
yourself from checking on them yeah then
you might have to do that
mm-hmm so try it for a couple of weeks
just I'm not looking at them yeah let
him go
just leave them if you can't do that
then delete them and leave the group or
whatever so number three should I attend
the reunion my answer that is negative
don't why would you
these people are negative then they
bring back negative memories they didn't
treat you well they but why would you
you don't need to move on again key word
I think move on and then the last
question is
why have they even been in my life well
I think just like anything else bad that
happens in life the things that are bad
that happened in life can either teach
you or break you and you got to decide
what you want them to do I vote that you
you allowed to teach you I vote did you
learn from these people that you learn
how to forget about the past that you
learn how to ignore people that are
negative that you learn to control your
vengeful ideas and that you learn to
move on into the future where you're
gonna meet better people and better time
should be at yeah that's what I would
recommend don't worry about these people
from the past they're caught up in this
weird world yeah high school this is
high school right we'll caught up in
high school world don't worry about high
school yeah get into the world
yeah right big time well I got I've had
one daughter that now graduated from
high school I had two kids in high
school right now yeah drama there's
drama but actually believe it or not
there hasn't been a lot of drama with my
kids yeah not on high school drama that
doesn't surprise me
yeah but but I see it it has happened oh
yeah and I remember the drama I'd say um
I guess I don't know it's been a long
time since high school for me personally
but yeah man I think that's life you
know I squeeze drama you a bunch of kids
not knowing nothing is there more drama
in high school than there is in life
maybe it's because it's stuck together
yeah you think your depends on your life
like you just consider a typical high
school versus my life yeah way more in
high schools I mean your drama that's it
really yeah yeah they're all high school
although even this guy obviously you
know so it's gonna feel like way more
than it is for sure but you know when
you when you the the further you go
along in life the more you realize that
this means less these types of things
anyway when you consider it high school
is really just for learning sure you
learn like oh sure
you learn things too you know what I
just thought of is is what's interesting
about this is if you're looking back on
high school either with fond memories or
with negative memories either way it's
not a great thing because you could be
like uncle Rico from Napoleon Dynamite
right constantly living back his high
school football games yeah yeah yeah and
he's wishing he made that pass and I
don't I mean what a state championship
or whatever yeah that's not good
mm-hmm right that you that means you're
stuck in high school you put it in high
school
yeah if you're looking back at the
negative things same thing yes and who
know move forward yeah in his defense
though obviously he just graduated so
he's life really is this really you know
new it's like you know someone stuffs
gonna happen brother you move on and get
after it yeah Polly the social media
thing now say this because there's
there's little levels of like
unfriending whether you can unfollow
someone I'm assuming this is Facebook I
don't know you know there's so many you
could be talking about of the stuff but
on Facebook you can still remain remain
friends but just unfollow them so you
won't get all their stuff do they know
that I don't think so they're nuts
I'm sure many people have unfollowed me
and I don't know that I've never
whatever um I would leave the group
fully oh yeah you're giving me your
advice more than me because I don't
understand as much as you do I get yeah
I don't understand the Facebook group
thing yeah I mean depends how many
people are in seem like who's gonna make
a scene I don't like to make a scene
yeah so I'd be like well no I'm just
gonna ignore it yeah I don't think
leaving the group is a scene if it is I
mean obviously depends on how many
people in the group is less people in
the group the more of a scene it's gonna
be or if he's always boasting if he's
the head of the group or something like
this then yeah you know how in the past
there was edited schools I went to I
went to etiquette classes when I went to
Austria and it's cool then that's all
the Florida and they teach you which
knife to use yeah yeah yeah and all that
stuff and they teach you things for
instance you might not know this if you
take a bite of food and there's
something in that bite of food that you
don't want to eat a bone or whatever the
way to properly get it
your mouth is to use your fork put it on
the fork and put it back down on the
plate it's like yeah gotcha they would
say the same so that's the type of thing
yeah there should be a class or we're
going to a point where people are
getting to class on social media
etiquette yeah actually that's not a bad
idea you should teach it all right let's
move on I hope things are yeah yeah
that's good yeah move on move on brother
yeah